sex is one of the things that's always
absolutely enticed about the Roman
Empire and the Roman Empire's was
represented there the place where people
did that frightful things and where and
since there were no sexual rules
anything went everybody had a good time
and there are enduring wonderful stories
about the excesses of Roman emperors and
their wives one of everybody's favorites
is the story of the Roman emperor
Tiberius who used to go off to his villa
in Capri where he had a great swimming
pool and he had specially trained little
boys who swam underwater while the
Emperor was swimming and nibbled his
genitals and he called them his little
minnows and it wasn't just the Emperor's
was a very famous Roman Empress
Messalina who's the wife of the slightly
doddery old Emperor Claudius and she is
supposed to have challenged the
prostitutes of Rome to a competition to
see how many men they could sleep with
in a single night and of course
Messalina
beat all the prostitutes now some of
this might be going on some of this but
I suspect that just as those kind of
exploits of Roman emperors are our
fantasies yeah can we think of the most
amazing things that people can get up to
so also they would have fantasies or
Roman writers to when they when they
kind of invented these stories about
people in power and I think there are
very very important differences between
ancient sexual behavior and our own but
they're not quite so clearly in the
level of absolute success and I think
for a woman I be the biggest thing the
biggest difference you'd see is a
complete double standard that's to say
in a ordinary Roman household the
woman was expected to be absolutely
faithful to her husband
no sex with anyone else the husband
it was quite all right for him to sleep
with the slaves male and female anybody
he fancied there was no such restraint
on him and of course that relates in a
way back to the basic anxieties and
worries of a very patriarchal
communities such as Rome but you know
the man's anxiety was always that his
wife's child was really his so you you
make sure that your wife sleeps with
nobody else but as for you it really
doesn't matter and I think one of the
bleakest places actually that you can go
to in the whole of the Roman world now
is the one surviving purpose-built
brothel in Pompeii it's certainly a
brothel is absolutely no mistaking it
and you walk into the front door and
there's five little cubicles narrow dark
just a single bed in them sort of wide
single bed and yet one lavatory at the
back and a very crude but erotic
paintings all over the walls and it's
the biggest tourist attraction naturally
now in Pompeii and people go in and they
they tend to think of the clients coming
here and you know visiting choosing
which girl to have and lots of graffiti
on the walls explaining in quite graphic
detail what they got up to you know hell
what kind of good time they heard but I
go in and I think gosh you know some
some people were working here you know
the working girls were spending their
life tending to the the sexual freedom
allowing the sexual freedom of the male
population while they lived in what was
essentially a cupboard dark gloomy
cupboard I think it's quite an
eye-opener when it comes to ancient
sexual norms which is a bit
more down-to-earth and the sexual
exploits of Roman imprison their lives